Петро Порошенко - один з найбагатших політиків в Україні.
Утім, інформація про те, скільки саме грошей
в українського президента, дуже розрізнена.
… пояснити, де ти, голубе сизий, взяв ці гроші?
Народ і суспільство має право це знати
За майже 20 років у великому бізнесі
Петро Порошенко встиг накопити чимало коштів.
Відтоді, як він став президентом, його декларації
вказують на зниження доходів.
Зокрема, за 2014 рік
президент вказав дохід у майже 369 мільйонів гривень.
За 2015й - було задекларовано понад 62 мільйони.
А за 2016й - більше 12-ти.
Попри це у скарбничці українського президента - чимало активів.
Окрім кондитерської корпорації Roshen,
яку він не продав, але передав у "сліпий траст",
у власності глави держави - Міжнародний інвестиційний банк.
Інтереси Порошенка присутні також в агробізнесі і медіа.
Крім того, президента часто пов'язують з автопромом.
Іще одна стаття доходів Порошенка - президентська зарплата.
На цій посаді приміром торік він заробив 336 тисяч гривень.
Утім, всю суму, як повідомили в його Адміністрації,
спрямували на благодійність.
Статки Петра Порошенка оглядачі оцінюють по-різному.
За останнім рейтингом, оприлюдненим у британських ЗМІ,
український президент увійшов в десятку найбагатших спікерів
Всесвітнього економічного форуму в Давосі, зайнявши дев’яте місце.
Його статки оцінили у 1 млрд 600 млн доларів.
Значно меншу суму вказували у своєму рейтингу
журналісти українського видання "Новое время" восени 2017 року.
За їхніми даними, активи президента оцінюються в 1 мільярд доларів.
Тим часом журнал Forbes, публікуючи свій рейтинг
найбагатших українських можновладців, оцінював статки Порошенка
у 2015-му у понад 940 мільйонів доларів.
Журналісти враховували готівку, кошти у банках,
нерухомість та автівки президента і членів його родини,
а також ринкову вартість його бізнесу.